[Musique]
la légende de dame tout a commencé par
un coup de foudre survenu lors de
festival hippie en israël lorsque la
chanteuse montréalaise lyla borgne a
rencontré le guitariste flambant nu boga
avec toutes les cheveux langue toute nue
avec sa guitare acoustique et viens
t'asseoir à côté de moi on a dit rien
quand y'a papa une moc qui se passe est
juste si les attaques ou des mois et il
joue et on a joué pendant neuf heures
ce google le guitariste principal et si
jouer en groupe le bassiste de la
tabatière en basse côte nord puis while
hôtelier nous on est tous teintés
apparemment le secret le mieux gardé du
canada du québec avant confinement de
dames tout donné près de 200 concerts
par année
leur musique est un mélange de janis
joplin et de led zeppelin on l'entend
partout mais on écoute cette musique là
toute notre vie alors c'est vraiment
pour nous entendre ça c'est comme moi
après neuf anciens numéros ça va passer
ou ça va casser avec leur troisième
album réalisé en partie à vancouver par
le producteur originaire de winnipeg
babrak connu pour son travail avec
metallica mötley crüe simple plane et
j'en passe c'est le moment que bob il
dit qu'il voulait travailler avec nous
je pense que je crée comme jamais créés
dans ma vie mais la compétition est
forte
des groupes de rock comme bret à 28 et
de tyrannie ont une longueur d'avancé
comment deux d'entre eux vont finir par
se tailler une place c'est sûr que c'est
une pente en mon temps parce que c'est
un groupe montréalais qui n'a pas
peut-être le support de deux groupes
majeurs américains mais le potentiel
rester là
dedans tout repartira en tournée en 2022
et comme le dit le dicton
ce sera sexe drogue et rock'n roll pas
dans la façon de le décrire ici
oui philippe ouimet radio-canada mots
rien